the town on the island of Cyprus also
looks like sludge City and indeed the
authorities here have been taken to
court over failings in its Waste
Management the state of the Cypress
sewage system leaves a lot to be desired
so maybe what we're seeing in this image
is a catastrophic sewage leak
turkey permanently quarantines the ghost
town to be used as a kind of bargaining
ship in negotiations over the Island's
future
it forces the residents to rebuild their
lives elsewhere
they were basically told that they can
never return on the threat of being shot
burosha becomes a time capsule the place
sits abandoned
like a movie set you might pass a shop
with Fashions from 1974 car dealerships
where you can see automobiles still
inside an airport with aircraft still
parked on their own way from 1974.